Francia en llamas Todos hemos visto
estas imágenes durante varias jornadas a
finales de junio y principios del mes de
julio el país galo vivió una vez más una
situación de absoluto descontrol las
protestas los saqueos el fuego y los
tumultos desatados en las principales
ciudades de Francia recorrieron el mundo
entero Claro que estas imágenes han
dejado de ser Algo extraordinario en
este país sucesos e imágenes más o menos
similares se repiten cada poco tiempo y
cada vez con más intensidad no importa
si hablamos de protestas y
reivindicaciones raciales o religiosas
de la final de la Champions de los
chalecos amarillos o de las reformas de
las pensiones la violencia empieza a ser
un signo distintivo en cualquier
movimiento social en este país la última
ola de disturbios provocada por el
disparo mortal de un policía contra
nahel con un joven de 17 años se saldó
con más de 5.000 vehículos calcinados
más de 1000 propiedades dañadas o
saqueadas 269 comisarías atacadas y más
de 4.000 personas detenidas una locura
sin embargo no nos engañemos porque
estas protestas no van a pasar a la
historia
[Música]
en la Francia de hoy la última ola de
violencia será tan solo eso la última
ola antes de que dentro de no mucho
tiempo se produzca la siguiente eso es
algo que va a ocurrir e incluso
seguramente lo haga antes de lo que nos
podamos imaginar porque queridos amigos
amigas de visualpolitik Francia empieza
a estar rota el país corre un serio
peligro de implosión y cada dos por tres
surgen las llamas es como si Francia
fuera una olla a presión cada crisis
revela tensiones un conflicto en la
sociedad nuestro país está
constantemente invocando valores
republicanos pero parece que segmentos
enteros de la población no sienten que
eso les importe Bruno cotre investigador
político en declaraciones a político la
situación ha llegado a tal punto que
durante las protestas el presidente
francés Emmanuel macron llegó a defender
ideas como estas macron sugiere bloquear
las redes sociales Durante los
disturbios Pero qué demonios está
pasando en Francia Por qué la sociedad
parece completamente rota que está
detrás de estas enormes de violencia Qué
consecuencias pueden tener queridos
amigos amigas En este vídeo vamos a
contar Cuáles son los tres grandes
protagonistas en todo este caos que cada
dos por tres se desata en Francia los
tres grandes protagonistas que nos van a
permitir entender mejor que es
exactamente lo que está ocurriendo Y por
qué París y las otras grandes ciudades
francesas se están convirtiendo en algo
así como las gotas de Europa solo que en
este caso sin que podamos encontrar
ningún Batman a la vista aunque como
veremos algunos lo pretendan vamos con
ello
[Música]
los van la mecha
queridos amigos para entender esta
historia tenemos que empezar
remontándonos hasta mediados del siglo
20 como en otras muchas grandes ciudades
de Europa y de América por aquel
entonces París y el resto de ciudades
francesas se estaban expandiendo a toda
velocidad la industrialización y El
Éxodo del campo a la ciudad estaban
multiplicando su población un fenómeno
que en el caso de Francia se vio además
acelerado por los procesos de
descolonización de su viejo imperio
Pues bien para dar una respuesta al
hacinamiento de las ciudades y a la
aparición de Auténticos barrios de
chabolas e infraviviendas a partir de
los años 60 comenzaron a crecer los
suburbios de las ciudades los famosos
valier lo hicieron en París en Lyon en
Marsella y en el resto de grandes
ciudades se desarrollaron bajo la
dirección del propio estado francés que
empezó a promover miles y miles de
decenas de miles de viviendas sociales
en estos nuevos barrios en los que por
supuesto también Se abrieron escuelas
centros médicos y líneas de transporte
público sobre el el papel la idea era
fantástica
con estos nuevos barrios y con las miles
de viviendas públicas construidas por el
estado los franceses más pobres No solo
podrían acceder a una casa sino también
un estilo de vida Mucho más acomodado
sin embargo queridos amigos los
problemas No tardaron en surgir ya
sabéis que de la teoría de la práctica
hay un trecho y que las intenciones no
garantizan resultados
Pues bien inicialmente la mayoría de las
viviendas se destinaron a los propios
franceses que emigraban del campo a la
ciudad pero estos en cuanto podían se
mudaban a barrios considerados mejores y
qué ocurría entonces con las viviendas
libres Pues que fueron adquiridas o
pasaron a manos fundamentalmente de
población inmigrante al mismo tiempo la
desindustrialización que París ha
experimentado en las últimas cuatro
décadas cerró las puertas a buenos
trabajos y buenos salarios para muchos
de los vecinos de estos mismos barrios y
así de esta forma estas zonas se
terminaron convirtiendo en algo así como
un sinónimo de pobreza y migración y
todo tipo de problema fracaso escolar
discriminación desempleo edificios mal
mantenidos delincuencia digamos que poco
a poco estos suburbios empezaron a
convertirse en Auténticos guetos
este fue un fenómeno especialmente
intenso para muchos grupos de
inmigrantes procedentes del Caribe de
senegal de Costa de Marfil de Marruecos
y sobre todo de Argelia que han
terminado viviendo en barrios separados
donde se mantiene la presión cultural de
sus países de origen y donde los niveles
de integración con la sociedad francesa
son relativamente Bajos en los últimos
años por ejemplo está llegando mucha
población de países como Pakistán y
claro como os podéis imaginar la
combinación de una cultura tan rígida
con un entorno de gueto es una bomba de
relojería
ahora bien no os penséis que esto ha
pillado a nadie de nuevas en 1977 el
gobierno de Francia ya mostró su
preocupación de que se estuvieran
formando gatos
[Música]
y aún más tan solo los últimos 20 años
el estado francés se ha gastado la
frontera de más de 60.000 millones de
euros en una colosal campaña para
renovar bloques de viviendas mejorar las
infraestructuras y acondicionar todo
tipo de instalaciones en estos barrios
particularmente los más pobres donde
viven más de 5 millones de personas la
mitad procedentes de Argelia de hecho
durante las últimas protestas Seguro
seguro que todos habéis podido ver cómo
se quemaban bibliotecas escuelas y
centros de salud y lógicamente si las
han quemado es que las hay la salud es
gratuita la escuela es gratuita y a
veces tenemos la sensación de que nunca
es suficiente Emanuel macron además
durante años también se han creado
montones de organizaciones pagadas por
el gobierno para intentar que las cosas
mejoraran sin embargo pese a todos los
esfuerzos Lo cierto es que los
resultados han sido bastante pobres los
van liu conocidos por sus altas tasas de
desempleo de fracaso escolar de
drogadicción de pobreza y de
delincuencia es un auténtico desastre
Porque además muchas de las personas que
viven en ellos especialmente claro están
los niños no lo tienen nada pero que
nada fácil para escapar de ellos y es
que queridos amigos amigas cambiar las
cosas materiales resulta relativamente
sencillo basta con tirar de chequera sin
embargo no ocurre lo mismo ni con la
cultura ni con las personas queréis un
ejemplo Pues pensad en las escuelas las
escuelas de estos barrios tienen unas
altísimas tasadas de fracaso escolar y
su nivel académico tiende a ser mucho
pero que mucho más bajo Esto hace que
muchos estudiantes se terminen quedando
por el camino
Pues bien El caso es que esta política
de vivienda pública que terminó
promoviendo Auténticos guetos es una de
las claves que explican Por qué Francia
tiene tantos problemas para integrar a
los inmigrantes Por así decirlo los
inmigrantes llegan a Francia viven en
Francia sus hijos nacen en Francia pero
realmente nunca terminan de ser
franceses ni ellos ni sus hijos al menos
no del todo y aquí los datos son muy
contundentes por ejemplo se calcula que
cerca del 50% de todos los niños que
viven en esta especie de guetos son
pobres el desempleo en estas zonas es
casi el doble que la media nacional y
por supuesto los ingresos de las
familias son mucho más bajos para que os
hagáis una idea uno de cada cinco
extranjeros que viven en Francia piensa
que es discriminado por su origen por su
raza o por su religión es una de las
tasas más altas de todo el mundo
desarrollado amigos Francia es uno de
los países que más problemas tienen para
integrar a los inmigrantes Y estos
barrios Tienen buena parte de la culpa
no me creéis Pues fijaos en este gráfico
todavía hay una sensación en estos
vecindarios Y probablemente una realidad
de que no tienes tantas oportunidades
como en otros lugares cuando ves a tus
padres y a hermanos mayores luchando por
encontrar trabajo estamos pagando por la
concentración de la pobreza la falta de
diversidad en las escuelas y la negativa
a construir viviendas sociales fuera de
estos barrios Olivier Klein ministro de
vivienda y asuntos urbanos y exalcalde
de cliché un municipio de los suburbios
orientales de París lógicamente todo
esto genera frustración y amigos no lo
dudéis la frustración es el mejor
ingrediente posible para alimentar la
violencia y aún no hemos terminado
para colmo en los últimos años han
surgido dos nuevos problemas en estos
barrios primero el narcotráfico el
suministro de cocaína alcanza un máximo
histórico en Francia el consumo de
drogas en Francia ha crecido un montón
en los últimos años se estima que tan
solo la cocaína tiene 1600.000
consumidores habituales en el país galo
eso evidentemente ha hecho que surjan
muchos grupos mafiosos que operan
precisamente desde estos barrios y por
otro lado está El problema del
integrismo religioso es precisamente en
este tipo de suburbios donde vive la
mayor parte de la población musulmana de
Francia y amigos la falta de
oportunidades el sentimiento de no
pertenencia y la frustración han formado
un gran caldo de cultivo a la hora de
reclutar fanáticos por ejemplo no sé si
os acordáis Pero antes de la pandemia
los atentados yihadistas en Francia
estaban a la orden del día Pues bien la
mayoría Fueron perpetrados por personas
de origen argelino que vivían sabéis
dónde exactamente en los que lógicamente
pues ha contribuido a crear una enorme
espiral de desconfianza violencia y
recelos quien no ha hecho más que
agravar el problema Por ejemplo las
personas de origen extranjero que viven
en estos barrios tienen 20 veces más
posibilidades de ser parados por la
policía más de 20 veces una policía que
no siempre es particularmente amigable
lo que nos lleva directamente al segundo
protagonista de toda esta historia
atentos
[Música]
la policía la gasolina
la policía es con diferencia una de las
instituciones más poderosas de toda
Francia entre otras cosas porque está
fuertemente sindicalizada la policía
amigos tiene muchísimo peso político y
en los últimos años el incremento del
integrismo yihadista las cada vez más
habituales protestas contra el gobierno
de turno y el aumento del narcotráfico
les ha dado todavía más peso para que os
hagáis una idea desde comienzos de siglo
prácticamente Francia aprobado una nueva
ley de seguridad que refuerza a la
policía cada año por ejemplo pueden
emplear armas intermedias en sus
patrullas en los suburbios algo que es
tremendamente infrecuente en el resto
del continente otro ejemplo se les ha
dado a los policías la facultad para
parar e identificar A quiénes de
absolutamente la gana Así que exista
motivo alguno incluso desde el año 2017
se permite a la policía de tráfico
emplear la fuerza letal contra cualquier
conductor que huya de un control de
hecho Aunque os pueda sorprender el caso
de Ángel marzo no fue algo inédito el 7
de junio por ejemplo apenas tres semanas
antes de la muerte de nahell la policía
de París mató a una chica joven de 21
años que supuestamente se había negado a
detenerse en un control el 14 de junio
dos semanas antes de la muerte de nahell
la policía también acabó con la vida de
un trabajador de reparto de tan solo 19
años un chico en otro puesto de control
y en total tan solo los 18 meses
anteriores a la muerte que desencadenó
las últimas protestas la policía
francesa acabó con la vida de 17
personas en controles de tráfico una
locura
Y eso eso no es todo en general Hablamos
de una policía que acumula un montón de
denuncias por excesos de todo tipo y que
como os podéis imaginar es muy poco
Popular en los suburbios y viceversa
según las encuestas los agentes de
policía se identifican
desproporcionadamente compartidos como
el de marile penn que piden mucha más
mano dura de hecho otras desatarse las
últimas revueltas Los Dos Grandes
sindicatos de policía utilizaron un tono
tremendamente incendiario llegaron a
decir que estaban en guerra contra
hordas de salvajes y que tenían que
acabar con la rata lo que bueno qué
queréis que os diga podéis tener la
opinión que tengáis pero no sé
declaraciones así no parecen invitar a
calmar las cosas no os parece poca broma
con la policía francesa de hecho esto es
lo que el propio macron decía en 2017
fijaos quiero cambiar la cultura el
estilo de gestión y el reclutamiento de
la fuerza policial Emmanuel macron en
2017 sin embargo luego llegaron los
chalecos amarillos las protestas por las
reformas de pensiones y demás y claro
macron ya no quiso saber nada de pegarse
con la policía y sobre todo con sus
sindicatos lo que le faltaba Por
supuesto que la policía sea incapaz de
controlar los suburbios y que la
población de estos barrios confíe
tampoco en ella no hace sino echar
gasolina al problema de los gatos que ya
hemos visto Claro que un momento porque
con toda esta historia no todo el mundo
sale perdiendo el tercer gran
protagonista de todo este desastre no es
sino el gran beneficiario de toda esta
historia alguna idea pues atentos
la extrema derecha la consecuencia
amigos la última ola de violencia se ha
saltado con un claro ganador Marín le
pen los franceses empiezan a estar
hartos y le Apenas ha habido capitalizar
Como nadie el momento le pen y su
partido aprovecharon los disturbios para
atacar al gobierno de macron pero
también para presentar un paquete de
medidas de mano dura por ejemplo la
agrupación nacional la formación del pen
quiere que a partir de los 16 años los
jóvenes puedan ser juzgados en procesos
penales como adultos tiene también que
los condenados por delitos pierdan el
derecho a vivir en viviendas públicas o
recibir cualquier tipo de pago
contraprestación del Estado también
quieren que se encarcela mucha más gente
y reducir los pagos sociales a las
personas que viven en estos suburbios de
los que os estamos hablando y sabéis que
todo esto es algo que empieza a gustarle
a los franceses y ojo no lo decimos
nosotros el 30 de junio se hizo una
encuesta que mostró que la respuesta de
la pena ha sido la mejor valorada de la
de todos los líderes políticos de
Francia La Escoria que vemos pillando
tiendas incendiando bibliotecas de
ayuntamientos todo mientras se ríen no
están haciendo esto por nael es una
excusa para atacar a la policía y todo
lo que representa a la república
diputado de la agrupación nacional y es
que pese a todo el apoyo a la policía ha
seguido siendo bastante alto entre los
franceses
segunda encuesta publicada por el diario
le Fígaro el 57% se puso del lado de la
policía Mientras que el 69% respaldó
declarar el estado de emergencia que por
cierto era otra de las peticiones de
Menudo tanto político amigos el caldo de
cultivo que se está gestando en Francia
es delicado por un lado está la
frustración de los suburbios por otro el
yihadismo luego tenemos a los partidos
más radicales creciendo a toda velocidad
y claro todo esto junto es la gran
amenaza de implosión de Francia un país
en el que ya nos podemos encontrar
noticias como estas recaudación de
fondos para un oficial francés que mató
a un adolescente recauda más de un
millón y medio de dólares Claro que un
momento porque esto no solo está
ocurriendo en Francia
[Música]
Lo cierto es que el tema de la
inmigración y sobre todo los problemas
de integración que han generado muchas
de las políticas que puesto en marcha
las últimas décadas se están
convirtiendo en un material explosivo
Francia recibe mucha atención pero no es
un caso singular aquí en visualpolitik
ya os hemos contado como Suecia esta
también teniendo serios problemas de
violencia en este país por ejemplo la
policía identificado a más de 30.000
personas que o bien forman parte o
tienen estrechas conexiones con las más
de 50 pandillas que han disparado la
violencia en el país nunca nos hemos
enfrentado a una criminalidad tan
despiadada el modelo de organización de
todo el sistema de Justicia sueco no
está preparado para hacer frente a una
criminalidad tan extensa andersonberg
jefe de la Policía Nacional de Suecia y
ojo con Bélgica o incluso Alemania en la
gran potencia Europea el número de
delitos se ha disparado lo que ha hecho
que la intención de Voto del partido de
extrema derecha alternativa por Alemania
esté subiendo como un cohete en total de
los 27 gobiernos de la Unión Europea tan
solo 6 inclinan a la izquierda y Dentro
de poco puede que sean aún menos en los
últimos 18 meses amigos ha producido un
tremendo giro político en toda Europa y
aquí la inmigración y sobre todo los
problemas de integración están jugando
un papel absolutamente fundamental por
eso llegado hasta aquí el turno y la
pregunta clave es exactamente para ti
cómo atajarías los problemas de Francia
la inmigración es imprescindible sí Y
además Tiene efectos económicos muy
positivos Pero cómo se puede mejorar la
integración de las primeras y sobre todo
de las segundas y las terceras
generaciones de inmigrantes dejadme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
hablamos debate y ahora si este vídeo se
resultó interesante no olvidéis darle a
like y suscribiros si es que aún no lo
habéis hecho una vez más Muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]